via con alex on occasions in alvin in
science can we have the apollo-soyuz
test project during the Cold War the the
country's cooperated in space and that
shows in principle how valuable the
International Space Station and the
space project are for the countries on
earth Linda LA and that we don't allow
day-to-day political events to affect
matters finding alexander gerst is
currently training at the nasa space
center in houston his tasks include
learning how to operate the scientific
equipment in the u.s. space lab called
destiny the german astronaut will be
responsible for conducting about 40
experiments including research on
robotics plasma and medals giris that
geophysicist and volcanologist has been
preparing for his mission for the past
two and a half years alongside acquiring
the technical skills he has to be able
to respond to onboard emergencies like a
fire in preparation for the installation
and maintenance activities at the
station he has to climb into a special
space suit he's practiced the necessary
hand movements for hundreds of hours in
a custom-built tool the simulations are
all in anticipation of the real zero
gravity experience
it was one of my biggest dreams to find
out how how the earth looks from space
how it is like when we humans travel out
into space what can we learn from that
Gerst will have six months in space to
answer those questions after the Soyuz
capsule takes off in May